the Star Trek franchise returned to the
silver screen with its highly successful
2009 reboot of the same name about a
decade later the whole series seems to
be stuck in limbo but just how did it
all go so wrong so fast
part of the beauty of the Star Trek
universe is how many different takes
visions and ideas fans are able to see
applied to the classic wagon train in
space formula over the decades many
different people have taken the helm
each with their own style of
cinematography concept of
characterization and visual flair some
love JJ Abrams slick take on the
enterprise and her inhabitants while
some prefer Gene Roddenberry's original
work and others are Deep Space nine
diehards and the wonderful thing is that
they can actually coexist everyone has
their favorite director just like
everyone has their favorite captain but
there is a downside to this directorial
shuffling and it's part of the reason
the films have run aground in the way
that they have Star Trek 4 has changed
hands more than once Quentin Tarantino
and SJ Clarkson were both rumored as
directors at various times then a
confusing pseudo clarification was made
stating that Clarkson's movie would be
separate and released before Tarantino's
multiple writers and producers were
named changed and named again no vision
was ever truly able to coalesce between
any of these creators and the fans had
nothing to Center their excitement
around I can see no appeal in either
option now the project has fallen apart
entirely and no one is even really
certain what might have been since the
film was never able to settle around any
one team or vision it just proves the
old adage right you don't want too many
captains on the bridge 2009 Star Trek
was a box-office smash as well as a
critical darling garnering a solid
little fandom of its own full of fans
who were more than willing to see more
of the enterprise's new adventures the
sequel into darkness was unable to
recreate the success of the first film
and constituted a step down for the
franchise both critically and
commercially but it wasn't a real
failure and so the Hollywood wheels kept
turning and Star Trek beyond was
released this film was a further step
downward since it underperformed at the
box office and ended up lost in the
midst of its competitors the writing was
on the wall Star Trek was traveling a
downward trajectory that showed no signs
of changing course any time soon a movie
is great as the first
Trek could turn anything around of
course but great movies aren't easy to
make and evidently the executives who
hold the purse strings didn't want to
take a risk
Star Trek 4 was a gambit and nobody
could guarantee that it would pay off
one thing that made the 2000s Trek
movies as success as they mostly were
was the cast
Zachary Quinto is Spock brought new
warmth to the famously chilly Vulcan Zoe
Saldana was equipping wonder as
lieutenant Uhura and even the smaller
characters proved to be nothing less
than outstanding people loved Star Trek
for a lot of reasons but there's a
reason the debates always comes down to
favorite captains because fans are
ultimately in it for the characters
there's no bigger personality on the
enterprise than Captain Kirk of course
and Chris Pine proved he could deliver
an irresistible take on the role Pines
charisma lit up the screen and became a
linchpin of the film's success but that
ended up being a curse as much as it was
a blessing
Star Trek 4 endured months of rumors
about casting turmoil and in August 2018
it was revealed that talks to secure
pine for the project had fallen through
there is no Star Trek without Kirk and
no Kirk without Chris Pine so now
there's no Star Trek at all back in 2009
Star Trek was in theaters blowing minds
with its unique brand of brash sassy
science fiction adventure but back then
the world wasn't used to that sort of
thing
Ironman was only a year old and the
scale and depth of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe as it exists today was still
just a twinkle in Kevin Feige Zhai the
idea of a talking raccoon with a tragic
backstory and a fondness for oversized
weaponry was practically laughable and
no one even knew who kylo Ren was yet
geek had yet to become chic and Star
Trek was pretty much the only game in
town nowadays however everyone knows who
Rocket Raccoon is and Saturday Night
Live is making jokes about vibranium
it's locked
maybe if you had some vibranium it would
open say what genre fiction once
maligned now rules the world and Star
Trek has been outstripped by Marvel Star
Wars and all kinds of other sci-fi
fantasy titans though the Star Trek
sequels were hardly flops the reality is
they weren't the smash hits they needed
to be to keep up with the likes of The
Avengers and the force awakens to be
merely passable ended up being an
unforgivable sin in the eyes of the
public and
we're all terrified of the first order
instead of Klingons Star Trek is a
franchise that spans many mediums but
its roots are in television and likely
always will be in 2017 the franchise
returned to its roots with Star Trek
discovery on the CBS all access
streaming service discovery begins
roughly one decade before the events of
the original Star Trek and follows The
Adventures of the crew of the USS
discovery led by anthropologist Michael
Burnham though it's run so far has been
hamstrung by what many see as the slow
starts and some wonky writing reviews
have trended upwards and viewership has
been decent unfortunately decent just
isn't enough the truth is that a
massively popular new installment of the
series could have injected the movies
with the adrenaline they needed to get
out of development hell but the numbers
simply aren't there
discovery is solid but not a smash good
for fans of Star Trek as a streaming
serial but bad news for those who want
more big screen adventures for the
enterprise and her crew check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]